adiante hoje eu queria agradecer a
oportunidade está aqui falando um
pouquinho sobre nosso trabalho
sou atleta profissional de stand up
paddle e único representante do amazonas
nessa modalidade que mudou minha vida e
tenho certeza que pode mudar a vida de
todos aqui é o amazônida por si só já é
um aventureiro né
desde criança a elas são acostumados a
correr na floresta tomar banho de
cachoeira
mergulhar nos nossos rios fazem trilhas
nossas florestas e eu agradeço todos os
dias por correr esse sangue aqui dentro
a ew 11 anos atrás
criei um projeto que é um programa de
televisão que era voltado para mostrar
essas coisas que são praticados os
esportes não convencionais que são
praticados aqui na nossa região como o
paraquedismo só pára quedista mais de 20
anos
tenho mais de 17 tem mais de 1.500
saltos de pára-quedas
sou faixa preta de jiu jitsu uma
modalidade que é bastante praticado aqui
na nossa região pelo fato do do nosso
contato do dos guerreiros que aqui
habitam a nossa cidade ea nossa região
então essas são algumas coisas que
costumam praticar e nesses 11 anos de
atividades esportivas relacionados à
amazônia eu conheci um esporte que cai
como uma luva que para nossa região que
chama stand up paddle
nós temos aí uma das maiores gráficas do
mundo o maior rio do mundo e por que não
utilizar ele da melhor maneira possível
a gente sabe que o nosso juízo as nossas
bacias estão bastante comprometidos
principalmente um dos lugares que é um
dos cartões postais da nossa cidade que
é o lago do tarumã
nós temos aí muitos dejetos sendo
lançados aqui no nosso rio eu todos os
dias naquela água ele treinando
praticando a modalidade esportiva e
apresentando esse esporte outras pessoas
nesses 11 anos eu tive a oportunidade de
ter alguns sonhos e um decisões já
realizei no ano passado eu ouvi uma
música uma vez que dizia que você só
consegue chegar em parintins ou de
bubuia ou de azar dura é uma das músicas
que tem aqui na nossa região de bubuia
seria de barco e arrasador o nosso avião
e eu mostrei que poderia chegar de uma
maneira
é diferente remando distenda pedra eu
remei por cinco dias
sair de manaus às 6 horas da manhã e
remova de seis da manhã às seis da tarde
eu não sabia o que aconteceu nessa
aventura porque eu não sabia como meu
corpo e se comportar
quais os desafios que eu podia encontrar
na frente falam que tem grandes bichos
aí soltos na nossa rio na nossa floresta
como jacarés cobra enfim tempestades que
também são muito perigosas e graças a
deus depois de cinco dias sai daqui na
segunda-feira na sexta feira cheguei em
parintins
antes do festival folclórico vai
conseguir o festival à noite
foram 12 horas ali por dia de muito
esforço e muito suor mas que valeu a
pena e isso trouxe muitos frutos bons
resultados além de parintins já tive
oportunidade de percorrer alguns outros
anteriores do município como uma web por
exemplo e é impressionante habilidade
dessas pessoas que são consideradas
menos favorecidas as pessoas que moram
na beira do rio com a habilidade de
remar
elas pulam em cima da prancha está em
remando como se já tivessem chamado a
vida inteira eu tenho 38 anos e na
semana passada eu acabei de realizar
mais um sonho na minha vida que vai ser
campeão brasileiro de stand up paddle o
único representante da nossa região a
competindo com os melhores atletas do
brasil a nível internacional e conseguir
trazer esse grande resultado para a
gente aqui com 38 anos e eu fiquei
pensando imagina a gente pega uma
criança que mora na beira do rio que
acostumada com aquele ambiente que não
tem medo nenhum do que aquele rio pode
oferecer pra ela e treinar essa pessoa
treinar essa criança dá uma alimentação
adequada pra ela dá um treinamento
específico para essa pessoa com essa
criança especial não só a criança como
adolescente jovens enfim adultos
eu tenho certeza não acho tenho certeza
que a nossa cidade nosso estado é um
fruto dá pra tirar muitas muitos
talentos aqui na nossa região pelo fato
de que ele já tem essa familiaridade com
o sport
e aí surgiu a idéia de criar um projeto
chamado superar
qual é a idéia de superar trabalhar essa
habilidade que essas pessoas têm que
moram na beira do rio já usaram a canoa
de certa forma
para se alimentar para se locomover você
no seu dia a dia então eles têm aquela
habilidade com remy então qual é o
projeto que chama superar que a gente
está criando desenvolvendo agora
percorrer os interiores do amazonas
levando esses equipamentos e
apresentando essas pessoas uma nova
profissão e interagindo justamente isso
com o turismo
a pessoa que vai no interior com certeza
gostaria de dar uma remada no rio de
conhecer de um outro ângulo que talvez
ela não conheça talvez só dentro de um
barco dentro de uma lancha mas tendo
aplicado a gente não polui não emitir
nada de poluente pro pro meio ambiente
pelo contrário a gente está fazendo bem
pra gente mesmo e para as pessoas que
estão praticando essa modalidade tem
vários exemplos disso aí então pessoas
que remam comigo que já perderam 15
quilos e já estão com uma outra
qualidade de vida com a autoestima lá em
cima eu tenho amigos que falaram que
prepararam deputter a pergunta por que
estavam tomando remédio para dormir à
noite se não conseguir dormir hoje sai
da atividade ele relaxada consegue
dormir sentado tomando remédio nada
então sup
como eu falei ele pode mudar a vida das
pessoas e o projeto superar é isso é a
gente está indo para os interiores a
capacitando as pessoas fomentando o
turismo no interior e dando uma
profissão que essas pessoas que a gente
julga menos privilegiadas mas que tem
uma experiência de vida uma habilidade
que não tem como a comparar isso há nada
é eu fico muito feliz de saber que o
nosso estado é um celeiro de talentos e
eu tenho certeza absoluta que logo - a
gente vai estar ouvindo falar sobre esse
projeto superar a lógica que eu vivo
hoje do stand up a minha principal fonte
de renda que o sustento minha família
vem do sup vendo stand up e eu quero
poder proporcionar isso outras pessoas
que essas pessoas consigam ter uma um
outro trabalho que elas consigam ter uma
fonte de renda relacionado ao rio
relacionado ao turismo e esse projeto é
lógico tudo que eu ganho na minha escola
20% do que eu ganho uma escola de surf
reverter esse meu projeto social eu dou
aula para crianças sem cobrar nada pelo
contrário a gente já tem um custo a de
deslocamento delas até a terra
a base pra gente fazer esse treinamento
nós temos também a alimentação dessas
crianças que elas precisam comer alguma
coisa e são crianças que você vê no
brilho do olhar delas
aí você vê que elas querem realmente
está ali querem estar praticando aquela
atividade
então assim pra gente é um prazer estar
aqui falando para vocês mostrando um
pouco do nosso trabalho um trabalho que
é um trabalho de formiguinha
eu comecei o trabalho em maio já tem
algumas crianças participando desse
projeto
meu próximo desafio é uma remada que vai
ser de novo airão até manaus são 125
quilômetros de remada eu preciso
pretendo fazer esse trajeto sem parar de
remar sair de lá mais ou menos meia
noite e chegar aqui em manaus por volta
de 6 horas da tarde uma remada que é nos
top como a gente costuma dizer
então qual a ideia e antes para no verão
levar os equipamentos em parceria com
governos e as prefeituras municipais a
montar uma base nesse município realizar
um treinamento adequado para as pessoas
que vão estar lá há associações enfim
vai ter que ser definido ainda e em cima
disso criar pólos nos interiores é
difundindo e divulgando essa modalidade
esportiva é essa minha amada até parente
já deu muitos frutos positivos
um deles é que eu tenho a possibilidade
de ser o primeiro atleta no mundo a
carregar a tocha olímpica uma nova sede
olímpica ea tocha vai passando por aqui
então eu tenho a oportunidade de a
primeira vez no mundo o primeiro atleta
no mundo está levando a tocha olímpica
no stand up paddle a minha história foi
pré-selecionada esse meu trabalho que
venho desenvolvendo aqui na amazônia a
essa história vieram para cá fizeram um
filme fizeram a tirar algumas fotos e
esse material foi enviado pelo cob
a resposta sai em fevereiro a gente está
numa a no pensamento bem positivo não me
rendi bem legal que vai dar certo e que
a gente vai poder trazer bons frutos
para cá é o meu maior sonho é ver se
interior repleto de pranchas de stand up
e poder contribuir com um pouco mais o
turismo e desenvolvimento da nossa
região
quero agradecer que há a presença o
convite que foi feito e quem quiser
deixa o supremo da vida de vocês que eu
tenho certeza que vocês vão gostar que
tiveram por
a unidade já estão convidados a praticar
obrigado